hey youtubers is Charlie so this week
for my Game of Thrones bonus video I
thought it'd be fun to talk about the
Blackfyre rebellion they're really two
Blackfyre rebellion so this video is
mostly just gonna be about the first one
I think I'll save a lot of the stuff for
the second one for my golden company
video just because a lot of their
history gets tied up in the second
Blackfyre rebellion real quick shout-out
to EJ Revis your this week's giveaway
winner you basically get to pick any of
martin's books or short stories I'll
message you on your channel for details
be sure to check your inbox hello to any
new people if you're just finding me for
the first time I'm doing weekly bonus
Game of Thrones videos until season 5
gets here which is a long ways away I'm
even doing a weekly book giveaway for a
Song of Ice and Fire
all you have to do to participate is be
a subscriber and leave a comment on this
video I basically pick one random person
and I'll just announce who that is
whenever I post my next bonus video next
Sunday so if you've never heard of the
Blackfyre name it's the surname given to
bastards of the House Targaryen it's
like snow in the north bastard names are
usually given mostly based on the region
you were born in so there really aren't
any new black fires being named on the
show right now just because there aren't
a lot of Targaryen running around
Daenerys is a proven Targaryen I know
there's a lot of theories about other
characters that might secretly be
Targaryen but if she ever had a child
that was a bastard she could name it
black fire although she's not really
that mean I don't think she would ever
name a child of hers a bastard it's a
historical custom that mostly takes
place from Westeros and while it seems
kind of derogatory not all Great Houses
treat their bastards the same which is
part of the reason the first Blackfyre
rebellion got started I think the best
example of a great house treating their
bastard really nicely is or espera thean
it's rumoured that he was the bastard
son of Aegon the conquerors father
aerion Targaryen making him a Gon's
half-brother that's like a whole other
story for another video but Oris was
like the Jon Snow of the Targaryen
family during Aegon's time so he ended
up getting treated like a family member
just like Jon does another more recent
example on the show was when Oberyn
Martell was talking about how Doran
treats its bastards down there all
bastards are given the name sand it's
not just bastards of the house of
Martell
so in Westeros there have been all kinds
of civil wars that have erupted for a
lot of different reasons mostly over
succession the Blackfyre rebellion was
just one of those if you've ever heard
about the dance of the Dragons or read
the princess in the Queen short story
you can think of it like the
at that Civil War was just a little bit
different and that it was a war of
succession fought between Targaryen
inside the line of succession
there weren't any bastards involved the
Blackfyre rebellion at its core was
Targaryen bastards versus Targaryen z--
ultimately the person to blame in all
this is the one who sired all the
bastards that was Aegon the fourth he
was king of Westeros a little over a
hundred years before events on the show
are taking place right now his character
shared a lot of similarities with Robert
Baratheon both in their girth in later
years and their prolific bastardy Aegon
like Robert had a lot of bastards
probably more a gun was way more
debaucherous than Robert though he lived
during a time when Targaryen power was
unquestioned there was a lot more money
to blow so he basically turned the royal
court into a harem he had at least nine
mistresses and the joke was his modified
Targaryen House motto was washer and
bring her to my bed instead of firing
blood so you get the idea he was like a
way crazier version of Robert Baratheon
although at one time Robert was one of
the greatest warriors in Westeros and
Aegon was arguably a douchebag his
entire life that's why he was dubbed
Aegon the unworthy but on his deathbed
he legitimized all of his bastards the
most notable one in this big conflict
was daemon Blackfyre that's his oldest
bastard he knighted him giving him the
Targaryen sword of succession also
called black fire
it was Aegon the first Valyrian blade
that was passed down to each new
Targaryen King whenever they took the
throne the Targaryen is being Valerians
had many valerian blades
it's just that black fire was the most
famous because it belonged to Aegon the
conquerer so wielding it was taken as a
sign of the right to rule so whenever
Aegon the fourth gave it to his very
young bastard son instead of his
supposed Targaryen son Daeron ii it was
a huge deal I say suppose a Targaryen
son because instead of being Aegon the
fourth son Daeron ii was supposedly the
son of his brother
Amon Targaryen the dragon knight it was
like a Joffrey Lannister Baratheon
situation everybody involved in the
situation seemed like they were only
having children with people who they
were not married to crazy I know that's
just how they did it in King's Landing
back then I guess my theory is is that
Aegon knew that darin wasn't his true
son but did know the daemon Blackfyre
so just out of spite to his wife Narus
for cheating on him with his brother
Amon he named Damon his successor and
remember Aegon was a party monster so he
obviously did not care for the rules of
court so he might have also just been
giving everyone the middle finger on his
deathbed too by naming a bastard his
successor if something like that were
gonna happen with the current characters
on the show it would be a lot like
Robert Baratheon naming Gendry his
successor when he was dying in season 1
instead of Joffrey I also kind of think
that Roberts secretly suspected Joffrey
wasn't his son Robert couldn't have
passed down a Valyrian blade to Gendry
he did have his Warhammer though which
was really really big it was supposed to
be so large that Ned Stark couldn't
swing it and Ned Stark wielded ice the
two-handed great sword if any of you
guys want to write some tumblr
fanfiction we're in Gondry takes
robert's Warhammer and smashes
Geoffrey's head like a grape just send
me a link after Aegon the fourth died it
was a long time before the actual
Blackfyre rebellion started the actual
war his Targaryen son Darren the second
succeeded him without any issues and
daemon continued to live in King's
Landing but over the next 10 years
tension between those two brothers or
half-brothers grew to the point of war
daemon Blackfyre was the one that
actually started the conflict he had a
couple really big gripes first was the
fact that his half-brother King Daeron
was marrying his sister Daenerys to a
Martell she and daemon were in love but
Darrin wanted to use her to bring the
Martel's into the realm Dorne was still
not part of the Seven Kingdoms at this
point
Damon's other big issue was that he
started to grow more and more resentful
about his bastard status despite having
been legitimized as a true heir and
possessing the famous black fire sword
we could probably also lay a little bit
of blame on his advisors but really this
is about a war started over a woman a
lot like Robert's rebellion daemon ended
up rallying a lot of bastards to his
banner most of them were fellow bastards
of Aegon the fourth remember there were
a lot of them and they all had families
of their own one of the other really
notable people that was part of that
initial group was Brynden rivers the
Bloodraven he ended up turning sighs by
the end of the war but he started out
fighting with daemon in case you didn't
remember
Brendan rivers is the three-eyed Raven
the person that bran met in the season 4
finale so the war went on for a long
time but the most famous battle was
called
Battle of red grass field the actual
field it took place on didn't have a
name the battle was just named red grass
because over ten thousand men died
during it just making the field red with
blood that battle ended up being the end
of the first Blackfyre rebellion and
daemon Blackfyre died during it and his
two oldest twin sons before he died
Damon had this epic battle with Gwaine
Corbray he was one of the Kingsguard who
also had a Valyrian sword they fought
for over an hour both of whom were
amazing fighters but Damon eventually
won remember Damon wielded the Valyrian
sword black fire and Korb raised
Valyrian sword was named lady forlorn
you have to remember lots of Lunarian
swords running around that time Damon
ended up winning the fight but his
half-brother Brynden rivers the
Bloodraven who by that time had switched
sides and was fighting for the crown
killed one of Damon's sons and then
killed Damon himself whenever he went to
pick up his sons body the Bloodraven was
a bit of a killing machine that day he
was basically sitting on a hill with a
bunch of archers just picking people off
as Damon lay dying on the battlefield he
passed his sword black fire to his other
son then the Bloodraven killed him too
which is kind of sad but there was a
little bit of revenge had one of Damon's
other bastard half brothers one of the
more famous ones bittersteel
fought the Bloodraven in personal combat
and took his eye out then escaped to the
east to form the golden company if you
remember during season 4 on the show
served a boast mentioned them so they
might actually be a thing that the show
does in a future season like I said that
battle was the end of the first
Blackfyre rebellion bitter still
basically took the survivors to the east
along with that black fire sword on his
deathbed on bitter Steel's deathbed
eventually he commanded his successors
to boil his skull dip it in gold and
carried before them as they later tried
to retake Westeros with a new army that
became the second Blackfyre rebellion
it's basically the reason the golden
company banner has all those skulls on
it it's the golden skulls of the former
commanders their motto is our word is as
good as gold because they've supposedly
never broken a contract but like I said
on to save all that golden company stuff
in the second Blackfyre rebellion for
another video be sure to subscribe to
get it also feel free to leave me
suggestions for other bonus topics like
if you want me to do another prophecy
video that video is going to post next
Sunday but tonight there's actually some
really cool Walking Dead stuff happening
we're going to get some new footage
from season five so I'm going to be
doing a special video for it you can
actually click here to watch it I should
post it around 10 p.m. Pacific time 10
or 11 p.m. I'm hoping and you can click
here to learn about my white Walker
prophecy theories I had a lot of fun
making that video too
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tonight high fives